schönen guten Morgen aus eigenem Ennstal
mein Name ist Wolfgang Luttenberger ich
bin der Kommandant der Luftunterstützung
des österreichischen Bundesheers ihr
habt uns ein paar Fragen gestellt
geschickt die ich jetzt gerne
beantworten werde die erste war was ist
der Unterschied zwischen dem Bravo
Modell und dem ma-modell erstens einmal
steht für militäre etwa
Modell das hinter mir hier steht ist im
Grunde für uns vorgesehen für die
Hubschrauber Schulung für die
einsatzpilotenausbildung und in weiterer
Folge dann auch für Einsätze wie zum
Beispiel Aufklärungsflüge Transportflüge
oder auch löschen zum Beispiel nach
Waldbränden die militäre advanced
Version hat dann zusätzlich noch
militärische Ausstattung wie Bewaffnung
wie Sensoren eine weitere Frage war
welche bewaffungsoptionen beschafft
werden das ist relativ leicht
beantwortet es werden dann Waffenträgern
dementsprechend ungelenkte bzw gelenkte
Raketen beschafft sieben Stück pro
waffenbehälter und des Weiteren eine
Bordwaffe mit 12,7 mm Kaliber eine
weitere interessante Frage war wo werden
die Lions wie wir sie taktisch nennen
stationiert das Bravo Modell das hinter
mir steht diese 12 Hubschrauber werden
in langen Lebern an der Flieger und
fliegerabwehrgruppenschule benutzt
werden und eingesetzt werden die
militäre advanced Modelle werden
einerseits in langer Leben und
andererseits hier am Standort in eigenen
Ennstal stationiert werden nächste Frage
war wie erfolgt die Ausbildung zum
Piloten für den neuen Leonardo
Hubschrauber nach einer
dementsprechenden Vorauswahl
psychologisch und natürlich auch von der
körperlichen Eignung geht's in die
Grundausbildung die findet auf der DA 40
einem leichten Flächenflugzeug in
Zeltweg an der Flieger und
pflegeabwehrgruppenschule statt danach
kommt die typenschulung auf dem neuen
Bravo Modell und wenn man das geschafft
hat dann kommt man entweder auf den
Black Hawk also noch auf einen größeren
Hubschrauber oder auf den militäre
advanced Hubschrauber der ein langer
Leben und in stationiert ist wenn ich
mit diesen Antworten Interesse wecken
konnte würde es mich freuen die eine
oder den anderen einmal hier in meinem
Verantwortungsbereich begrüßen zu dürfen
sei es als zukünftiger Pilot
luftfahrzeugtechniker im Flugraum
bewirtschaftungsbereich im Bereich der
flugbetriebsdienste Feuerwehr tankwegen
was auch immer ihr seid herzlich
willkommen und ihr könnt euch gerne
informieren auf der bundeswehrseite
karriere.bundesherr.at bis zum nächsten
Mal
[Musik]